hi guys I'm Ralph from simply alone and
welcome to this video on how to install
Eclipse IDE on your Windows 10 operating
system now an IDE is an integrated
development environment on this computer
programmers can perform software
development now eclipse is one of
several in the market like IntelliJ
bluej dr. Java and so on now to install
eclipse first you need to install Java
this is because if you try to run the
Eclipse installer this shows up the
shows that you do need Java before you
can install eclipse on your operating
system so first let's go and download
Java and let's search for Java installed
now here we have the latest version
which is version 13 we're not going to
pick that one up we're going to go to
version 8 now we choosing reaction 8
because this is one of the most commonly
used versions of Java so let's select
this so we'll go down all the way here
and here we can see two options the 64
bit and the 86 bit
so this basically represents the 32-bit
operating system so if you do have one
you can select this option since we have
a 64-bit operating system I'm going to
select this but before the installation
you need to accept license agreement and
select this now I've already logged in
so I'm just going to install now let's
select this quarter notes click on this
and then this shows up we'll go to next
we'll go to next and let the install
complete so here we have another pop-up
so if you want to change the destination
folder you can select this option this
is fine with me so I'm going to cover
next that's it let the installation
complete now so there you go the
installation is now complete so if you
want to look at tutorials or
documentation you can go to the next
steps and want to so let's close and go
back now just because we've installed
Java we can't exactly run it yet for
that we need environment variables now
environment variables help the computer
understand that it needs to run job when
it sees a dot Java fell for that let's
go to the control panel let's go to
system and then let's go here and select
advanced system settings and then this
shows up now before we can set the
environment variables we need the path
to where Java is installed so let's go
to file explorer
let's click C Drive let's go to Program
Files so this is where I install Java
go to Java first let's go to GD game and
bin let's go back here click on
environment variables select a path here
go pirates copy that and press on new
and paste this now likewise let's go
back go to GRE which is the Java Runtime
environment and JDK which is the Java
development kit click on this go to bin
and select this path go back good path
select new and face this as well
and there you go the environment
variables are now set let's click on OK
and that's done now let's install
eclipse let's go back again and search
for eclipse in here select this option
to come down load select 64-bit so when
this shows up so I've already downloaded
it so we can directly go there I'm gonna
click on this now so now we have the
installer show up so here you can choose
from a number of different options like
C C++ PHP and so on
so you want this one we click on this
and here we can just install will accept
and there you go the installation is
going on right now
we'll remember accepted licenses accept
this you need to accept these
certificates accept selected and there
you go we're complete let's launch so
now we need to set up a directory so I'm
ok with this so let's launch and there
you go here's the workspace so let's run
a very simple program now so we'll close
this and here you have the package
Explorer let's open this up so in case
you can't access the package Explorer go
to window click on show view and select
package Explorer now first to run a
program you need to create a Java
project click on this and let's name our
project let's go to next and here you
see SRC or source now this is where the
source code of your program is now we
just finish that's that now we go to
source right click new and create plus
now let's create a class plus one and
finish and now we should be able to run
any program you want let's look at the
very simple code of writing HelloWorld
so let's open the main function let's
open a bracket here let's print and
that's that now let's run the program by
clicking on this cycle let's select the
class and there we go we have an output
this means the program is running
successfully and with that we've come to
the end of
this video I hope you guys found this
informative and helpful thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
simply lon
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here